deux individus sont donc été interpellé
hier soir ils sont soupçonnés d'être les
auteurs des tirs qui ont fait sept
blessés à beaune dans la nuit du 29 au
30 juillet dernier
les deux hommes ont été localisés dans
le var puis placé en garde à vue depuis
la nouvelle ce matin dans le quartier
saint-jacques de bonnes c'est le
soulagement
sur place les précisions de gabrielle
talon après l'annonce dès
l'interpellation de deux individus hier
soir est bien ici c'est clairement un
soulagement depuis treize jours les
habitants du quartier saint-jacques
vivait dans l'angoissé et dans la tente
de ces interpellations pour être certain
que cette agression ne soit pas impuni
je vous propose tout de suite et bien
d'écouter les réactions de deux de ses
habitants que nous avons pu rencontrer
ce matin je pense que ça va être un
soulagement et les gens ont besoin de
savoir d'où d'où ils viennent quoi c'est
c'est légitime de se poser ce genre de
questions c'est vous êtes qui vous venez
d'où et pourquoi pourquoi agir de telle
sorte quoi tomber pour les victimes
parce que comme ça au moins la justice
va être fait et puis que le calme va
être dans le quartier parce que on y vit
beaucoup ici j'ai quand même accompagné
puis à un enfant donc voila quoi
empêcher contente pour les victimes et
piqué à eux y prennent soin d'eux épique
que tout aille mais pour eux quoi autre
motif de satisfaction ici et dias et la
qualification des faits par le procureur
les deux hommes sont gardés à vue pour
tentative d'assassinât et violence
aggravée par trois circonstances dont la
motivation raciste du passage à l'acte
reste qu'ici dans le quartier saint
jacques on veut désormais savoir qui
sont ces hommes
d'où vient-il et pourquoi ont-ils commis
ces actes
on attend une communication du procureur
de la république dans les prochaines
heures
elle devrait intervenir à l'issue des
gardes à vue des deux hommes interpellés
et puis il n'y a plus qu'un jeune homme
blessé
toujours blessé et hospitalisé à dijon
une sixième victime est sorti de
l'hôpital ce matin hier dans la soirée
le procureur de la république est revenu
lui sur les moyens déployés pour
procéder à l'interpellation de ces deux
tireurs présumés
vous trouverez les détails dans un
article internet